d'accord on reste concentré
moteur offert demandé bien sûr ces
buttes et cinq sur six soutien action
regrette pas mes droits
je vais pas te pas l'air bien
sans directement par me consoler ça vous
êtes disputer c'est ça
je préfère pas en parler coupez
s'écouter
l'accueil du travail d'acteur cei sous
texte
c'est quelque part ça quand quand je dis
tout la recherche sur ce qu'on met en
scène veut raconter parce que bien sûr
qu'ils allaient mot action
mais je suis plus qui a dit un jour que
les mous c'est un échec on dit n'est pas
ce qu'on a envie de transmettre
donc forcément si elle est ou qui sont
écrit très bien et ça mais elle veut
dire quoi donc c'est pour ça le metteur
en scène il veut dire quoi en racontant
ce film-là est quelque chose qui lui est
vitale
donc forcément le chercher le sous-texte
du film
et puis du personnage est forcément là
où tu opur en tout cas une couleur du
personnage à la couleur que tu vois toi
aurait renforcé avec la couleur de tes
autres partenaires et ton metteur en
scène bien sûr on commence par le début
alors oui papa pourquoi c'est moi c'est
remplir et la banque qui a dit lancer
mais on s'est rencontrés parce que aussi
retrouvé sur un court métrage qui était
c'était un premier court métrage et moi
aussi c'est tout les deux autres
premiers courts métrages
ça c'est un hasard je dirais de vie
ouais de vie de désir en tout cas d'être
comédienne
les deux clubs belges aussi non non et
en plus moi j'arrivais de d'afrique en
fait je n'ai pas grandi en france et
j'étais donc encore un petit peu
inadapté à cette société occidentale et
natacha était aussi médina pas soro
ancien match de qualité au tiff elles
étaient deux qu'on avait l'impression
d'un oiseau que qu'elle parlait très
très peur et quand je dis très peu
réellement ça ne peut passer des heures
entières à observer sans un mot et elle
faisait des petits sont quand même quand
elle apprécie vocal après ce n'est pas
laid et puis après moi je la voyais dans
d'autres moments où on était nous deux
ou demain et là où il y avait quelque
chose dit il
c'était une chose quoi moi je n'aurais
jamais pensé que natacha allait devenir
la personne qui a les mains du mois
c'est quelque chose que j'aime chez les
gens
qu'ils aillent jusqu'au bout d'un rêve
je pense que c'est une chose magnifique
il ouvre cette porte mal courir après
des chiens butin n'est pas son chien
j'en ai rien à d'être humilié
trempe ne s'est pas été milliers
jusqu'ici à qui nos vies de mères
traitées comme de la merde
rien à tu portais pas nous là
dedans le dos avec les maires de suez
mais faut que tu te sort de la tête ce
matin la sensation que j'ai en tout cas
dans le court métrage dans la vie rêvée
des anges sait que la tâche allait ce
qu'elle a réussi à faire sortir là et ce
qui était toute la beauté pour moi de ce
travail est d'ailleurs je pensais ça
aussi 4 qui transperçait c'était une
chose intérieur et est immensément
violente et intérioriser qui sortait
d'un coup et qu'elle est libérée du mari
je crois qu'on a pu rien à faire
ensemble je vais partir sainte asie mais
tu crois que tu arrives à te reprocher
mais qu'est ce que tu sais faire à part
t'accrocher aux autres comme un boulet
qu'est ce que t'as courage de faire
toute seule vente des cartes c'est ça
non mais tu vas aller loin avec ça à ton
mais c'est une fille largué du doigt
même pas je vais te dire moi ce qui
t'est coeur c'est que j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un que ça marche
c'est simple tu arrives pas ravalé ouais
tu crois que ça avec triste que tu vas
t'en sortir ouais ouais bah si tu
rappelles passé qu'il veut plus de toi
ah ouais t'es dans sa tête je les ai vus
il me l'a dit qu'est ce qui t'a dit il
m'a dit ce que je ne te dire que c'est
fini voilà c'est tout ah ouais tu leur
as vu quand il ya trois jours
pourquoi sera bien edouard toit m'est
venue voir manquer ce qui l'a même pas
le courage de te le dire en face
c'est tout un et vas-y mais elle va
l'appeler si on fera pas valable et
connaît même pas dit avant nous mais
nous en quoi tu vas tu moshé parce que
j'ai pas tu te dire à mon butin il
atteint 22 rames dire la vérité mais je
te le dis la vérité c'est toi qui peux
pas longtemps et c'est tout cette
enquête et loire c'est au jet il
faudrait tous amenés là dedans
qu'est ce que tu as été revu récemment
tu es jeune tu viens barge la city faut
que tu te calmes arrière du magazine ne
pas mettre dix ans à tu peux même pas
imaginer ce qui se passe entre nous des
cages vas t'occuper de l'autre morte la
sq a que ça intéresse les cadavres
jamais ça ou je te tue
maintenant chacun pour soi
bac en ligne scène comme ça m'a dit vas
y ait à la fois la joie évidemment de
devoir voilà que savary et que forcément
les trucs qui varient c'est passionnant
a fermé ses vj arrivé je peux y arriver
est ce que ça va sortir à sortir ce que
ça va être ridicule pas ridicule et et
puis est le truc de jeter à l'eau pour
le pour la faire mais mais on n'est pas
seuls quoi il à l'autre comédien il ya
il ya tout ça après ski ce qui m'a
frappé dans celle là précisément c'est
que en fait il ya il ya deux choses que
je fais que je devais pas faire et que
c'est vraiment tout d'un coup la scène
qui a débordé ça a débordé moi je devais
pas fini 9 et en fait je dire sous la
barre et j'ai refilé direct
et puis je prends le couteau et je jette
au couteau et en fait ça me le fait que
je parais que que je pleure à moitié et
tout ça ben parce que j'ai filé une
baffe et que vous avez pas fini de ma
fait parce que tout d'un coup y'a un
truc qui retombe et du coup je pars en
traînant les pieds voilà on y comment
après des scènes comme ça fatiguée
tu t'isoles du web tu es là toute façon
principe de mari dans la vie rêvée c'est
qu'elle est quand même très isolés même
si elle habite à côté 10 à elles restent
isolés et j'étais vachement isolé par un
choix d'eric et puisque je vais pas
faire autrement à l'époque
après y'a eu cannes quand on a entendu
mon nom comme qu'on avait le prix
d'interprétation
je pense que j'ai vu comme un espèce de
grand blanc comme un choc où j'ai été
bouleversée et après les césars je pense
qu'elle estime de moi que j'avais
tellement pourri je pense que c'est un
cadeau du ciel parce que je sais pas si
j'aurais pu
maintenir debout bien
oser parler je vous ai pas parlé c'est
un permis à roger par les sarabandes
permis de tenir droite donc pour plein
de gens c'est un truc très
glorifiant valorisant et moi j'ai
l'impression que j'ai une estime de moi
tellement pourri c'est vraiment un
cadeau du ciel
voilà et puis d'avoir comme ça quelques
personnes dont le côté artistique a été
reconnu depuis longtemps que tout d'un
coup je rencontre les êtres humains ils
sont derrière les artistes ouais ça m'a
beaucoup touché
je t'attendais depuis donc au dessus
donc ou téléphone était sur tt seul
parce que c'est
ainsi taxé comme bagage séduire
mitrailleurs ont cherché non manger tous
là j'habite au troisième ça ira
c'est au petit chemin enfin c'est pas
vraiment chez moi mais tu peux être
fatiguée elle est brossé par contre je
t'assure
là j'ai rencontré en fait juste après
cannes je devais pas reconnu il a posé
un regard
justement rempli destine à la
c'est ma vie je n'ai pas de chance
je pleure à maintenant
on
c'est vraiment un très bien sous les
projecteurs c'est pas fini je sais me
fait un peu déjà un petit peu parlé d'un
soutien jeu est tout nu c'est non plus
tellement plus forte du personnel je lui
ai demandé mais michel et pas des fois
un autre ancien te manque quelque chose
et tu sais pas le faire
il m'a dit mais tu sais déjà ce que tu
proposes à au metteur en scène c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'ils pensent et
et c3 mais ça m'a rassuré mais rassurés
et s'adonner de la liberté michel tu
sais pas du tout à la phrase d'après ce
qui va sortir
il ya une inventivité de tuchan quelque
chose de très généreux mais tu sens que
un envoi vincent françois vincent
françois paul et les autres est une
scène comme ça avec sa femme tooba
police met en colère parce qu'ils
l'aiment et que l est par ailleurs et ça
explose mais tu sens qu'il ya un truc
comme ça sous jacent qui peut partir on
ne sait pas où ni comment
moi j'étais beaucoup plus timide mais
méchante et effectivement des choses
comme ça où avant l'essai ne sais pas
comment je vais faire et je le vivais
plutôt mal au départ parce qu'il y en a
voilà il arrive ils ont construit très
impressionné par sa niveau là mon
personnage choisi tel geste elle machin
et un jour une actrice qui arrivent et
qui vise en tel film tu fais avec ta
bouche incroyable et où moi je me
sentais super content parce que je sais
absolument pas que j'avais fait un truc
avec ma bouche et qu'en fait il y en a
vraiment comme ça qu'ils ont des choses
de construction et ses magnifiques et
chez que je fais pas ça parce que je n'y
arrive pas parce que je n'y pense même
pas et qu' il ya une partie où ça sort
mais il ya une partie très inconfortable
parce que en fait chaque fois je me dis
et si ça sort pas aujourd'hui sur le
film de benoît jacquot deuxième jour
corsetée
40 degrés l'acteur en face joris acteur
de théâtre 80 ans toute une autre école
tout une manière de faire sans que les
années ont donné un tempérament
particulier et je me suis retrouvé face
à lui juste fais peur
le texte justement avec les mots c'est
un texte plus j'avais un peu des longues
phrases enfin j'avais l'impression que
c'est des longues phrases tout d'un coup
ce matin là je fais à ma merde voilà
cette fois ci je rêve
où allez-vous vous savez bien couvent de
sainte anne au couvent de sainte anne
vous y êtes déjà allé la semaine
dernière je vous avait autorisé une
seule visite par mois vous avez promis à
la mère supérieure que je serai libre de
me rendre auprès d'elle je n'ai rien
promis
thème blanche de cette chaleur de ce
corset de l'acteur en face c'était
pendant pas mais est en fait elle est
face à lui elle a exactement sentiment
là donc oui je n'arrivais pas à dire
mais à la fois c'était le personnage qui
était comme ça un acteur première jouer
j'ai l'impression qu'il va très très
bien se connaître est vraiment apprendre
à ne pas juger les paras nombre des gens
oui surprendre avec des attitudes
différentes face à la vie dans le choix
des rôles ce que tu as des gens qui
lisent pour toi est ce qu'il ya des gens
qui conseillent j'ai plus d'indépendance
aujourd'hui sur sale mais mais j'aime
bien faire à venir donc selon ses longs
qui est proche de moi à ce moment là la
vie ça change tout le temps
oui j'aime bien quelqu'un qui dise parce
qu'il ya quand je dis la première fois
je l'aï vraiment d'une manière joly à
travers le prisme mon personnage est
travers le prisme de qu'est-ce que je
vais d'abord faire donc je vous dis et
scénario avec une mauvaise foi
épouvantable je vais lire très très mal
jouer
qui croire
oui oui et je sais au rez de chaussée
vous voilà
merci qui me sort
d'accord
et wall street
c'est l'écart
parfois j'apprends tout seul parfois
j'apprends avec quelqu'un je sais que
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour moi
d'apprendre avec quelqu'un parce que le
texte tout seul les maux avec la
dyslexie licenciés mais les mots c'est
plus du tout les mêmes
et puis quand il ya quelqu'un sur le
plateau des fois les mots c'est plus les
mêmes
pourtant la maison je le sais au rasoir
pour moi les mots comme une couleur et
tout d'un coup les lettres s'efface
c'est comme si elles n'existaient pas il
moment de tourner je me souviens de la
couleur est donc ce n'est pas le bon mot
qui sort s'il ya quelque chose que je
comprends pas je vais au moment du
tournage poser des questions je
comprends pas lassana je comprends pas
je comprends pas pourquoi ça ça va là où
j'ai besoin d'un tournoi coup oui c'est
chez si je sais pas où elle en aide qui
me le rappelle que voilà sur le film de
retenir est le silence et tout d'un coup
une chose à la fin par rapport aux deux
personnages je comprenais pas et je
voulais pas comprendre
c'est ce qu'elle fait
tu crois
on arrive à la montagne à la toute fin
et on a pris une jeune femme qui va dans
la montagne nature laissent partir la
jeune femme qui partait de la voiture il
partait tout seul est en fait la de la
voiture je devais rester à la voiture et
je trouvais ça impossible qu'elle reste
planté sur sa voiture
impossible je paraissais la voiture je
suis rentré dans le champ et puis du
coup il ya un échange de regards entre
personnages et le personnage de mathieu
et je trouvais ça super important parce
que je ne savais pas à la fin un plan
qui vraiment nous nous raconte que ce
couple est solide
là j'aurai vraiment eu l'impression
d'être arrivé d'avoir nagé dans la
rivière de la montagne et de faire
saluer revoir et donc de coust disait je
faisais pas un filmeur je faisais des
vacances en corse
du coup j'étais tout d'un coup
extrêmement têtu et j'en ai marre de
l'est pas et voilà après évidemment
comment je les fais je lui ai laissé la
possibilité que le coupé s'est vraiment
il avait envie de couper parce que c'est
son fils mais je suis pas metteur en
scène et et voilà mais mais mais quand
même
et puis après il m'a dit qu'il avait
essayé de monter sans ce plan là et
qu'effectivement ça avait du sens et que
du coût de la vie
sur le film de chantal akerman tout d'un
coup le personnage et elle a dit ce
qu'ils voulaient pas d'enfant qu'il
voulait pas voulu être enceinte qu'elle
supportait plus son mari et que est
juste je me disais mais mots que la
raconte là mais je comprends même pas ce
que ça veut dire
je peux pas concevoir que je me sens
tellement de maternelle que je sais que
ça existe
je sais très bien mais je ne pouvais pas
l'intégrer donc je vais je vais devoir
dire des mots je sais que ça existe mais
je peux pas l'intégrer dans mes
sensations
comment est ce que je fais un personnage
comme ça que tout d'un coup plus voir
son mari elle ne supporte plus qu'elle
veut absolument pour la première fois de
sa vie elle rentre dans un endroit que
ça sent bien que tout est en cours elle
ne veut pas de cet enfant est elle au
bord d'accoucher est la mienne venait
d'avoir un an et tous beaucoup moins la
maternité c'est une espèce de
révélations incroyables et je menu je
suis pas dans la merde moi ici et est
donc j'ai vraiment aimé travailler
travailler chercher c'est de comprendre
comment je pouvais intégrer ce
personnage là est en fait j'aime ta part
aller à chantal je lui ai pas demandé
j'aurais pu lui dire chantal je fais
dans ma merde totale parce que là
vraiment je comprends même pas comment
je peux le sortir ce personnage je me
suis juste focaliser sur ce texte et
réfléchir à plein de choses l'humeur de
tempérament de sentiments de choses je
pouvais l'accrocher à quelque chose que
je connaissais et à partir du moment où
j'ai trouvé la porte d'entrée
grand sourire j'étais soulagé c'était
bon mais ça je veux pas leur raconter la
porte d'entrée
ça c'est un secret c'est le secret vous
voilà et puis après en ayant trouvé
cette porte d'entrée
oui c'était cohérent que je lis ça que
que tout ne voulait pas cet enfant que
ton impose le plus mon mari qui poussa
les informant que tu vas mourir si je
n'aime pas il va recommencer se
transforme toujours après l'accouchement
et puis on dit aussi que quand un groupe
de déminage c'est la faute de quoi du
couple ce que j'ai envie d'aller là où
j'étais surprise était sûr sur demain en
déminage parce que le rôle était
tellement difficile c'était qu'elle
tellement je sais pas si drôle était
difficile ou pas mais la situation était
tellement difficile faire ce qu elle
faisait était tellement inattendu
tellement surprenant tellement il ya un
mois je connais peu d'actrices qui
aurait fait ça avec cet aplomb la cette
assurance et cette façon de ne pas y
toucher quoi une présence qui s'impose à
la première à la première apparition
déjà sur le plateau elle arrivait boom y
avait peu l'impression que que c'était
là et qu'elle s'imposait dans quelque
chose de décalé de d'inattendu de drôles
de légers de de déjantés c'était très
très surprenant et là par rapport à la
vie rêvée des anges effectivement sonova
a pas grand chose à voir
et voilà c'est une espèce de solidité en
toute circonstance qui était qui était
très très impressionnante et donc après
dit l'actrice qui peut faire et la vie
rêvée aussi bien et demandé ménage aussi
bien être bien à peu près partout enfin
je vois pas où elles ne seraient pas
bien
oh
au go
or death and life as we sur le souhait
bonnes pour que tu resterais pas dans le
même état
parce que je me suis perdu la note on va
l'entendre parce que la laisse entendre
ou en ouvre des portes
et va être pas ça c'est mal à faire
entendre et on me dit quel est l'intérêt
simple
paris
pas gagné
e
elle fait paniquer c'est vrai elle va
continuer de chanter parce que rien ne
se referment d'accord sans match qu'est
ce que j'ai fait mais tu fais tu fais
pas assez d'accord tu fais pas de la
musique à nice
voilà comment s'occuper de nos data news
coeur mis sur pied
gaudy
ça vient natacha s'il n'y a pas à côté
le corps qui travaillent la tête ça fuse
un peu trop quoi donc
donc le penchant des deux fait vachement
du bien et elle cours de chant il ya une
manière dans l'expression dans dans la
façon de travailler avec ce professeur
là mais je pense que dans toute manière
de travailler le chant il ya quelque
chose de plus large que ma manière de
jouer en tant que comédienne et et de
manière inverse d'exprimer des
sentiments et l'a en fait je trouve
achement le côté de travail d'acteur
avec elle
j'adore ça chanter j'ai toujours adoré
ça ma mére de chanter chanter tout le
temps dans la voiture mais elle a aussi
chanté dans des chorales ou la fontaine
et du classique mozart et plein plein
d'autres elle voix sublime et je sais
pas donc ça a toujours fait partie
mon pari il était dj au départ et il a
toujours été passionné par la musique
donc on avait toujours de la musique
classique adam et il nous est plein
plein de cassettes de deux variétés
françaises n'ont pas peur qu'est ce que
tu veux tout qu'est ce que tu me veux tu
crois qu'il me regarde comme ça c'est
qu'ils me rien ça me faire croire que je
m'intéresse pas je suis trop vieux c'est
pour les épaules ne devrait que tu me
laisses maintenant j'ai du travail
une fois non mais tu me donnes ton
adresse parce que tu es le rouge non
loin de la fabrique appartient bien
demain je veux pas demain
à tout à l'heure
est ce que le fait que ça soit loin de
toi je comprends que ça serait
jubilatoire et qui est un truc
composition mais peu compliqué moins
compliqué bah le fait qu'on sait loin il
ya comme une accroche on va amener
quelque chose
donc il ya une accroche avec une
distance
donc c'est plus confortable après ça
peut être plus casse-gueule mais c'est
plus confortable quand c'est plus près
ça fait vibrer plein de choses
donc y'a un truc plus joué avec le feu
il ya un truc qui est extrêmement aussi
attirants parce que ça brûle
et oui on sait pas trop trop ainsi on
s'est un peu parce qu'on voit le
parcours du truc mais ça va forcément
secoué et hélas il ya un truc ambigu
c'est quand même temps ça fait plaisir
d'être chamboulé comme ça et quand même
temps ça fait peur
la séquence est proche tu sais ce que
c'est qu'une communion
oui je sais ce que c'est une communion
quand je te fais goûter quelque chose
bordel de merde c'est une communion
entre toi et moi un truc pas sans doute
que toi et moi est-ce que tu saisis
j'adore ce genre de scènes voudrais pas
tu sais ce que c'est vous dira pas tu
sais ce que ça représente pour moi y est
vous êtes je lui dise non vous ne pouvez
pas goûté désolé je suis en pleine
communion avec mon mari d'isoler c'est
moi qui ai le droit et personne d'autre
sinon il va me faire une de crise
avec sa commune aux joues
mais j'ai l'impression que je peux faire
plein de trous pour les personnages
seraient pas mon avis donc donc c'est
aussi un espèce de prétexte de faire des
choses je ferai jamais
c'est pas moi mais comme je les vis
j'étais venu pour de vrai il ya une
chose un peu comme ça qui est un peu un
peu bizarres et des choses en vigie tard
pour de vrai c'est du jeu mais on est en
en a' les émotions et les sensations
enfin en tout cas moi beaucoup un acteur
et donc il ya parfois dans les
personnages qui sont très sombres et des
scènes horribles
en fait tu fais là s'est réjoui avec un
sourire d'une oreille à l'autre et des
fois un passage de porte ou j'ai juste
pas y arriver
faites donc des choses comme ça donc
c'est vrai que je peux y aller il ya le
personnage qui qui ont envahi et que des
fois quand il ya deux choses pas drôle
ça fait bien bouleversant mais qu'en
même temps il peut aussi avoir un côté
complètement jubilatoire de d'avoir
justement laisser aller l'émotion
qu'elle est bien tricorps et que trop
bien noir est bien sorti et puis c'est
pas mal ça avec avec le personnage d'un
film de jeunes green qui est oui était
vachement sonné
mais une fois fait ça m'a donné beaucoup
de joie de l'avoir fait
entre
qu'est ce que c'est ce bruit bestial tu
es censé être chanteuse
personne ne va plus me dire que je dois
prendre des meuleuses française même
pour faire plaisir au ministère chez
nous les vaches sont mieux que ça je ne
comprends pas cette violence
c'était tellement plus lent que j'ai
envie de vomir
tu as le timbre d'un kangourou étrangler
et en plus tu n'as aucun sens du style
baroque
je ne demande qu'à prendre
recommençons si tu veux guigui c'est
sans espoir
elle ferait mieux de chercher une place
de caissière chez tati fais pas ce
métier pour un mouton flageller et je
fais pas ce métier pour rentrer nominera
mais que va-t-on dans la vie à des trucs
assez dramatique comme ça que pour en
rajouter dans le travail que le travail
on accepte aussi à des moments de
plongée justement dans des choses
sombres qu'on accepte de raconter plein
de choses qui est des choses où on se
livre malgré tout il ya un an malgré nos
os tout ça est et tout d'un coup d'aller
casser pour obtenir un pleur ou entre
que je suis pas d'accord quoi vraiment
ça mon ça me rend enragé points je
déteste ça
et il ya même un moment donné il ya eu
un monde un peu de désespoir on va dire
coupé et j'ai rencontré emmanuel
bourdieu emmanuel bourdieu dans sa
manière de travailler
c'est sur la confiance j'ai pas comment
vous le ressentez ben moi je sens que la
situation ne peut finir que comme ça
mais malgré tout c'est elle qui embrase
on enfume comme ça dans ce sens ça sinon
je trouve ça marche très bien mais je
sais très bien aller le silence s'il
vous plaît sinon s'il vous plaît action
couper c'est pas la peine de retarde
énormément mais en même temps il ya un
petit temps du fait qu'ils sont déjà
ensemble quoi déjà c'est vous êtes un
peu serein comme si sa playbook mais
cela me plaisait beaucoup
les est vrai comme initiative vient de
toi en jaune je suis champion s'est
passé très vite
de son côté à lui sous ses forces et
sauf qu'elle elle c'est pareil c'est
l'histoire de maturité démocratique qui
fait que l'homme sinon ça fait un peu
voilà ça fait un peu de la petite fille
qui fait est ici montrent une baraque et
tous appuyé à prix queila qui attend tu
vois c'est pas bien sous c'est pourquoi
c'est ça qui est bien d'accord tu vois
ce que je veux dire ouais d'accord
la tâche est pas quelqu un qu il faut
pousser à bout pour obtenir des choses
bien d'elle au contraire il faut plutôt
et même des choses extrêmes on peut
l'obtenir simplement en nous parlant
calmement en lui permettant de se
reposer un qui peut avant peut-être même
denis podalydès il a fait rigoler avant
une prise et ben elle a encore plus
détendu et là encore plus bouleversantes
après elle pleure mieux d'avoir rigolé
avant quoi jeu et moi je tiens beaucoup
à ça parce que pendant longtemps et
aussi toute une mythologie on m'a un peu
fait parc pour être au metteur en scène
il fallait être les falette espèce de
deux chefs fallait être un peu louis de
funès dans la grande vadrouille
c'est vrai qu'on ne viendront enfin
espèce de toscanini quoi et donc moi je
me disais moi j'y arriverai jamais donc
c'est pas fait pour moi mais je sais que
maintenant c'est possible avec des gens
comme natacha justement c'est quelque
chose de girofle bloquer les émotions
c'est un peu plus loin et l'acteur aussi
et que je crois pas non à l'école de
cette violence là ça peut arriver quand
ça arrive c'est très inconfortable et au
contraire je peux te tautou blindés
faire le truc tout seul tout en dieu et
tout ça est que si elle la confiance bas
je peux lâcher proposer plein plein de
choses et n'estime une confiance une
distance juste je revive plein de fois
avec jeu puisqu'elle est important
on aurait dû parler
de ma vie de ma vie nul à paris donc
pour donner deux
nulle d'un important dans ma vie lui dû
annuler et pourtant serge j'en ai marre
ont beaucoup de comédiens disent que ce
programme officiel ajoute que quelqu'un
qui habite maintenant mais moi je me
tiens je sais que c'est très dur c'est
de moi en plus on a tâché enfin moi je
suis vraiment pas danseur mais je sais
pour un comédien c'est très difficile
aussi de danse et surtout quand il ya
douze figurant dans une salle de bal
points contre 81 le messie un rapport 1
parce que le relâchement que suppose la
danse et surtout la danse avec quelqu'un
de sensé être amoureux est un truc et je
jouais en même temps la comédie ou un
déjà ça joue ça me met pas ce concours
vous ayez arriviez quoi dans ce truc là
le truc de kanté vivre sa passion pour
faire en fait quand quelqu'un et aireth
bourema au contraire il veut pas trop
enfin métier en plein de trucs donc
mais c'est ça que ça vous voilà pour moi
c'est exactement on avait parlé si c'est
l'idée que je trouve très très beau
c'est ses devoirs non pas l'ivresse me
voir quelqu'un qui se bat pour pas qu'on
livre c'est très agréable de travailler
avec un pascal pour une comédienne et un
peu comme denis podalydès et des
comédiens son narcissisme c'est très
agréable des chantiers sont payés pour
être en représentation
c'est leur pareil d'être en
représentation et et n'ont aucun un
regain fonds pesant sur eux mêmes
c'est quelque chose je l'entends pas m'a
pas dit ce que tu pensais
une capture
comédie
il faut
avec anne fontaine il ya une scène où
elle voulait plus de pleurs et du commun
sa dernière après c'est fini
après deux films c'est fini je les
regardais et gérer vraiment une bascule
d'éclats de rire parce que je comprenais
ce qu'elle faisait où diable et le
pleurer
et donc j'ai fait la première réaction
c'était que j'avais envie d'éclater de
rire parce que je savais pas mais
c'était tellement voilà que c'était pas
l'âme une manipulation nous demandez pas
content
et du coup je fais pas les bascules aux
pleurs me dupriez quelque chose de super
joyeux quand tu sais pas quand il sait
que c'est pourquoi c'est très joyeux et
tu te laisses faire voilà et après même
si tu as pleuré comme je sais pas quoi
tu sors est un grand sourire
quany de la manipulation et que tu sais
pas tu parles en une en vraiment dans
dans l'humeur du personnage sans recul
et et la prépa pour moi la prépa est
super important de savoir par où passe
le personnage parce que même si sa
marque
complètement j'ai quand même un certain
recul terre je vois je vois ce qui est
en train de se faire je vois ce qu'il
fait à l'intérieur je vois ce que le
personnage fait donc même si je suis
complètement envahie et complètement
dedans j'ai pas mon regard dessus et
donc ça me je peux rentrer à la maison
un peu secoués mais je rentre à la
maison c'est que j'ai des chances et
luis dos
même si je regrette on n'est pas dans
parfois on n'en veut pas bon je voulais
vraiment c'est nina c'est faux ce que
j'aime du coup si je crois mais c'est
risqué pour moi alors vous l'a
déconseillé
oui c'est jean luc qui me suis je peux
avait d'autres médecins depuis des
années parfois c'est bien d'avoir un
autre cabinet ça m'arrive d'être jalouse
la rue dans le parc
je vois toutes ces bonnes femmes
enceintes béate je trimballe leur
poussette
ce que je sais par hasard ce métier il
ya vraiment quelque chose je pense
qu'ils avaient quelque chose à
l'intérieur et après je vais bosser
bosser bosser bosser bosser je pense
parce que je l'avais pas bosser wii sera
faite pas où ça n'allait pas commencer
mais mais oui il ya vraiment quelque
chose de ma personnalité qui correspond
à ces métiers et où je m'exprime par là
où je transmets par là avec des choses
très joyeuse et très fort ayant tu es
très mais aussi des choses qui sont très
douloureuses et il ya des moments sur
ces choses douloureuses j'en ai marre
bon j'arrête je vais dans le larzac je
vais élever des chèvres j'en peux plus
parce qu'il ya des choses qui secoue et
où il ya un prix à payer et à des
moments je fais mon nom c'est trop long
je veux pas foutez moi la paix dégager
tous je veux plus faire ce métier mais
en même temps ces choses qui sont
compliquées j'ai l'impression que même
si j'ai loué des chèvres dans le larzac
se seraient présents et un jour je me
suis rendu compte de ça que les choses
qui avait été compliquée dans ma vie
avant et qui ont fait que
jeanne est vraiment super mal c'est
aussi ça qui fait que j'ai la force dans
mon travail et que donc ça servait à
rien de fuir ces choses que je supporte
pas qu'il faut que je fasse ce métier
parce que ça a été la toujours et quand
en fait part à d'autres et manger c'est
de fuir ça quand j'étais petit et tout
d'un coup j'ai filmé en fait dans mon
métier il ya ça carrément en fluo
j'ai pleuré toute une nuit et je me suis
dit non mais merde alors
c'est là et puis à des moments quand je
n'eus ras-le-bol de ça dans le métier je
vais dans le larzac
ce sera là aussi je prends rien faire
donc c'est la part compliquée du métier
mais ce qui est marrant c'est qu'en fait
comme à d'autres horizons pareil et donc
moi vous cacher à côté d'eux parce que
tout d'un coup il ya me sens moins seul
de sa voix là
drive de son pointu
kraken
m
i want you to god of war est
de drague de belles teintes et volailles
oh
comme il faut
du concret
tout
avec un lieu de six
m
je trouve que quand on est acteur on
peut vraiment gardé très présent sa part
d'enfance qu'on a en soi et j'adore ça
c'est chouette
oh
youtube
ouais
tu
tous
je veux
holmes
du gatt de what you